le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
écologie environnement développement
durable
ces questions sont de plus en plus
d'aborder partout dans le monde à la
réunion aussi des actions se mettent en
place et ça commence dans les écoles à
saint-andré le collège de cambuston a
été récompensé de l'écolabel pour son
engagement écologique
[Musique]
on est en train badamiers un flamboyant
day - tamarinier l'autre côté c'est une
histoire qui prend ses racines dans le
passé le bal damier flamboyants ont été
plantés à l'ouverture du collège 76 déjà
plus de 40 ans les autres arbres ont été
plantés des élèves depuis les années 90
à l'origine de l'aventuré
la passion de jean marie et d'un
collègue professeur on était amoureux de
la nature déjà et puis on a été soutenu
par le principal de l'époque monsieur
mahoudeaux et donc on a eu envie de
replanter parce qu'il manquait d'armes
ça fait plaisir de voir que ça continue
et que ça continuera après je pense que
ça va la chaîne v est enclenché
car depuis le projet a bien géré mais à
saint-andré cet établissement de
cambuston est labellisé eco collège un
label national délivré aux
établissements qui s'inscrivent dans une
démarche de développement durable
l'herbe du sentier était devenu plus
verte et plus grasse
non loin de là un petit bois bordé un
vaste près la nature
un thème abordé désormais dans toutes
les classes dans quelle partie sono de
l'oeuvre ici en cours de français mais
aussi en svt ou en physique chimie dans
le jardin
les élèves ont créé un bassin dacquois
pony la travée 105e système a promis ça
consiste en quoi ça consiste en fait à
faire pousser les plantes et à nourrir
les poissons écologiquement grâce à tout
un système
alors comment ça marche c'est une pompe
qui va aspirer l'eau et qui vont en fait
ramené tout ça dans les bacs qu'on a
recyclé et donc ça va être filtrés par
les scories et donc les écrivains des
poissons vont être dans les scories et
l'eau va retomber net dans le bac
l'eau c'est le thème du collège cette
année les élèves ont travaillé sur
divers ateliers visant à lutter contre
le gaspillage de cette précieuse
ressource
c'est un système de goutte-à-goutte en
fait ça récupère l'eau en bas et sa peau
jusqu'aux à arroser pas
c'est un cycle cette classe a recréé
grandeur nature un mur végétal sur
l'enceinte de l'école on appuie que de
l'arrêter pour pouvoir faire pour
montrer justement que comme le collège
et éco labellisés donc on appris que du
matériel de recyclage on a fait ensemble
autant fait dérailler la ola pour un peu
manuellement c'est mieux être de nice
alors on ferme et on peut avoir les ja
la mâture
décloisonner les matières les idées les
élèves c'est la volonté de l'équipe
pédagogique
cette année en 2017 2018 nous abordons
un thème transversal qui est le climat
alors aussi bien le climat sur le plan
environnemental mais le climat aussi le
climat scolaire donc la notion de
bien-être de l'élève au collège et ses
différents projets permettent
différentes actions permettent à l'élève
de se sentir mieux au sein de son
établissement le fait de travailler sur
la métaphore cela nous permet d'unir les
différentes disciplines autour de ces
projets là
une méthode qui se révèle payante
certains élèves consacrent désormais
leur temps libre à l'entretien du parc
des 600 points potager on a planté des
honneurs
l'amant radio show ici et après près de
chute il dit moore fra ger d'état et si
la mémoire leur fait parfois défaut non
paradis l'intérêt de ces ateliers lui et
bien acquis d'habitude les gens baysa
chez ted atp mais après sa facilité
produits toxiques dessus comme ça aussi
que chez nous qui a planté et c'est bio
l'application des élèves mais aussi des
parents des professeurs et de tout le
personnel fait de ce collège en exemple
ce qu'on espère c'est vraiment une
reconnaissance de des différentes
compétences des élèves une
reconnaissance aussi de ce qui est fait
dans cet établissement de l'est enfin à
l'est et voilà se retrouve un petit peu
en avant en arrière je tairai alors qu'
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de volonté
grâce à son engagement l'établissement
est labellisée depuis trois ans déjà
mais il a surtout planté les graines
d'un avenir meilleur sur leicester moche
qui est pollué
après la fausse est pas parce qu on va
profiter du bon mot vert de pollution
donc voilà chaque fois que tu as
accompli ce geste de planter curan à la
terre ce que tu lui as pris sur veille
sur elle elle fait surtout ainsi que le
font les prisonniers
[Musique]
l'éco label a été créé en france en 2005
objectif aider les élèves à mieux
comprendre le monde qui les entoure
pour mieux le protéger tout en
s'épanouissant le collège de cambuston à
saint-andré est labellisée depuis trois
ans il mène toute l'année des actions
comme la création d'un jardin des poètes
à mur végétal mais aussi des ateliers de
recyclage et les opé rations
alimentaires pour plus d'informations
sur l'éco label vous pouvez vous rendre
sur le site www.ecoquartier.ca org
[Musique]